RIGHT. SIENNA. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE. HAPPY TO SEE ALL OF
YOU IN THIS ROOM TODAY, TODAY WE
HAVE ONE BILL ON OUR AGENDA, AND
WE HAVE, MEMBERS THAT ARE
PRESENT. SO I WOULD LIKE TO GO
AHEAD AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
SO, ASSISTANT, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL? SENATORS HURTADO
PRESENT. HURTADO, PRESENT.
GROVE. ALVARADO. GIL CORTEZ.
CORTEZ. HERE PADILLA. PADILLA.
PRESENT. OKAY. A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED, WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
MOVE WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE,
AB 2113 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA, CAN YOU PLEASE COME UP
AND PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY? GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. AND COLLEAGUES OF THE
SENATE. I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
AGENDIZING THIS IMPORTANT MATTER
. AB 2113 MAKES CHANGES TO THE
MILL ASSESSMENT AS WELL AS OTHER
POLICY CHANGES UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION. WE INTRODUCED THIS
BILL TO GIVE THE LEGISLATURE AN
OPPORTUNITY THROUGH THE POLICY
COMMITTEE PROCESS TO HEAR FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AND MAKE FURTHER
ENHANCEMENTS AND REFINEMENTS TO
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ADDRESS ISSUES RAISED BY
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE LEGISLATURE.
SINCE THIS BILL WAS LAST HEARD
IN COMMITTEE, THERE HAS BEEN AN
AGREEMENT REACHED BETWEEN THE
ASSEMBLY, SENATE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. THIS BILL HAS
BEEN NEGOTIATED ON THE SAME
TIMELINE AS THE BUDGET. AS THIS
IS IMPLEMENTING LANGUAGE THAT
WAS PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR AS
A TRAILER BILL IN ITS LANGUAGE.
THE RECENT AMENDMENTS STRIKE A
COMPROMISE, AND IN A COMPROMISE,
THERE IS A GIVE AND TAKE. AS YOU
ALL ARE AWARE, HERE ARE SOME OF
THE HIGHLIGHTS OF THAT
PARTICULAR COMPROMISE. ONE,
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT TO
COMPLETE THE REGISTRATION OF
PESTICIDES WITHIN A SPECIFIED
TIME FRAME BEGINNING IN 2027. IT
REMOVES THE AUTHORITY OF THE
DEPARTMENT TO RAISE THE MILL
ASSESSMENT IN THE FUTURE, AND
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT TO
INITIATE AN ADDITIONAL
REEVALUATION OF A PESTICIDE A
YEAR UNTIL 2029, AND THEN
INITIATE AN ADDITIONAL TWO
REEVALUATIONS OF A PESTICIDE
YEAR PER YEAR RAISES THE MILL
FEE INCREMENTALLY OVER FOUR
YEARS TO A MAXIMUM OF 30 MILLS.
THE BILL HAS SEVERAL PROVISIONS
OF ADDED TRANSPARENCY, REQUIRING
THE DEPARTMENT TO POST CERTAIN
INFORMATION, SUCH AS TIMELINES
OF PESTICIDE REGISTRATION OR THE
ESTIMATED TIMELINE OF COMPLETING
CERTAIN REEVALUATIONS ON ITS
WEBSITE. ADDITIONALLY AS HAS
ADDED ACCOUNTABILITY, THE BILL
REQUIRES THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT TO APPEAR BEFORE THE
RESPECTIVE LEGISLATIVE POLICY
COMMITTEES OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE NO LESS THAN AT LEAST
ONCE EVERY TWO YEARS. THE
DEPARTMENT HASN'T HAD A FEE
INCREASE IN ALMOST TWO DECADES.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE A
PROPERLY RESOURCED DEPARTMENT
THAT IS WELL POSITIONED TO
BETTER CARRY OUT ITS MISSION.
FOR THOSE REASONS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND GETTING OFF SCRIPT A
LITTLE BIT HERE. I JUST WANTED
TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
WORK OF ALL OF THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE INVOLVED IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS, AND IT'S
TYPICALLY PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT
USUALLY ON THE SAME PAGE WHEN IT
COMES TO, NOT JUST INTEREST, NOT
JUST, CONSTITUENCIES, BUT I
THINK THIS ISSUE BROUGHT THEM
ALL TOGETHER, WITH ONE COMMON
GOAL IDENTIFYING THAT THERE WAS
A NEED TO BOTH REFORM, THE
DEPARTMENT AND THAT THERE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WERE
NEEDED, TO ENSURE THAT THE
MISSION OF THIS AGENCY IS FULLY
ACCOMPLISHED. AND ALONG THE WAY,
I THINK IT WAS IDENTIFIED AND
DISCOVERED THAT THERE IS A LOT
IN COMMON. AS IT PERTAINS TO THE
CONSTITUENCIES THAT WE'RE ALL
TRYING TO SERVE AND IN MANY
INSTANCES ALSO PROTECT. AND SO I
WANTED JUST TO COMMEND ALL OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO CAME
TOGETHER TO STRIKE THAT
COMPROMISE. AND I'M GLAD THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO BE PART OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND JUST WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK OF THE
GENTLEMAN TO MY RIGHT AND HIS
TEAM IN OUR COMMITTEE. FOR
PUTTING THIS WORK TOGETHER, WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. AND I WOULD
IMAGINE THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
FOLKS THAT WILL BE STEPPING UP
TO SAY A FEW WORDS AS WELL.
THANK YOU AGAIN. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA, AT THIS
POINT, WE'LL TAKE, OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE HERE IN
ROOM 113. PLEASE COME UP AND
STATE YOUR NAME, ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION. OKAY. SEEING NONE,
WE'LL MOVE TO ANY LEAD
OPPOSITION ON THIS MEASURE.
SEEING NONE. IS THERE OTHERS
THAT WOULD LIKE TO STATE THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE HERE
IN ROOM 113, PLEASE COME UP AND
STATE YOUR NAME, ORGANIZATION
AND YOUR POSITION. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, NICOLE
QUINONEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION. ACTUALLY
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL BUT WANTED
TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO THANK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER, THE SENATE,
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR WHAT IS IN
PRINT TODAY. AND JUST HIGHLIGHT
A FEW POINTS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALSO MENTIONED, FOR MY
CLIENT, WE REPRESENT THE NON
AGRICULTURAL MANUFACTURERS OF
PESTICIDES AND THE NON AG SECTOR
CONTRIBUTES ABOUT HALF OF THE
TOTAL MILL ASSESSMENT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT USES TO CARRY OUT
THEIR DUTIES. SO WE HAVE THROUGH
THIS PROCESS ADVOCATED FOR THE
INCLUSION OF REGISTRATION
TIMELINES FOR OUR PESTICIDE
PRODUCTS. SO WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO
SEE THOSE INCLUDED IN THE IN THE
LEGISLATION. WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE TRANSPARENCY MEASURES THAT
ARE INCLUDED, AND WE THINK THOSE
WILL BE VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE YEARS TO COME
AS THEY TRY TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THESE RESOURCES HAVE ACTUALLY
RESULTED IN BETTER SERVICES, AND
THEN FINALLY, REALLY APPRECIATE
THE REMOVAL OF THE AUTHORITY
THAT WOULD HAVE GIVEN THE
DEPARTMENT THE ABILITY TO RAISE
THESE TAXES IN, OUT YEARS, AND
WHICH WAS ORIGINALLY PROPOSED,
BUT IS NOT IN 2013 TODAY, AS WE
BELIEVE, THAT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT PLACE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE THESE
DEBATES IN FUTURE YEARS IF THEY
NEED ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MADAM CHAIR,
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, LOUIS
BROWN HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
AND I'M GOING TO ACTUALLY READ
THE LIST SO THAT YOU UNDERSTAND
THE DIVERSITY OF CLIENTS THAT WE
HAVE, THAT HAVE BEEN FOCUSED ON
THIS ISSUE. AMERICAN PISTACHIO
GROWERS, CALIFORNIA CITRUS
MUTUAL, CALIFORNIA COTTON
GROWERS, AND GINNERS
ASSOCIATION, CALIFORNIA FRESH
FRUIT ASSOCIATION, CALIFORNIA
TOMATO GROWERS ASSOCIATION,
CROPLIFE AMERICA, WESTERN PLANT
HEALTH ASSOCIATION, NISEI
FARMERS LEAGUE, THE CALIFORNIA
WALNUT COMMISSION, CALIFORNIA
STRAWBERRY COMMISSION, WE'RE ALL
NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL, WE STARTED
IN OPPOSED. WE MOVED TO OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED. WE MOVED TO
NEUTRAL WITH CONCERNS. TODAY WE
ARE NEUTRAL ON THE BILL AND WANT
TO EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION TO
THE AUTHOR. THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE, YOUR STAFF, THE ASSEMBLY
STAFF FOR REALLY BRINGING
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER. THIS WAS
NOT A TYPICAL BUDGET TRAILER
BILL, AND I APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP OF MR. GARCIA OF
SAYING WE WANT THIS SUBJECT
MATTER TO BE DISCUSSED IN A
POLICY BILL BECAUSE IT IS
SUBSTANTIVE POLICY THAT ALSO
IMPACTS THE BUDGET. BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY, WE AGREE THAT
THE DEPARTMENT NEEDS ADDITIONAL
REVENUES WITH THOSE REVENUES,
THOUGH, COMES THE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND SO, AS NICOLE JUST STATED,
THERE WERE SOME CORE PRINCIPLES
THAT WE HAD GOING INTO THIS
NEGOTIATION. ONE WAS THAT THE
MILL BE CAPPED IN STATUTE AND
THAT WAS HELD, AND THEREFORE IN
ANOTHER FOUR YEARS, THIS
LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO COME BACK AND
EVALUATE WHETHER OR NOT THOSE
BUDGETARY RESOURCES OF THE
DEPARTMENT ARE ADEQUATE. WE ALSO
WANTED TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. WE ARE HELD
UNDER MUCH DIFFERENT STANDARDS
IN CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE THAN
THE REST OF THE NATION. AFTER A
PRODUCT IS REGISTERED AT FEDERAL
EPA, IT MUST COME BACK TO THE
CALIFORNIA BEFORE IT CAN BE
REGISTERED HERE TODAY. ON
AVERAGE, IT TAKES MORE THAN SIX
YEARS TO GET A PRODUCT THROUGH
THE REGISTRATION PROCESS. IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE AND IT JUST CREATES
A DISADVANTAGE FOR OUR GROWERS
IN THE STATE BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
GETTING THE SAME ACCESS TO THE
NEW CHEMICALS. THE SUSTAINABLE
PRODUCTS THAT OTHER GROWERS AND
COMMODITIES IN THE COUNTRY HAVE
ACCESS TO. SO THE REGISTRATION
TIMELINES IN THE BILL, THE
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES, THE
ANNUAL REPORTING IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL SO THAT WE CAN ASSESS
WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE GETTING THE
RETURN ON INVESTMENT THAT COMES
WITH THE INCREASE FOR THEIR
BUDGETARY AUTHORITY. SO WITH
THAT, WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF EVERYONE INVOLVED AND
ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRIS REARDON, CALIFORNIA FARM
BILL, WE ALSO HAVE REMOVED, OUR
OPPOSITION AND MOVED TO NEUTRAL.
I ALSO WANTED TO THANK MR.
GARCIA FOR AND JOSH FOR THEIR
INVOLVEMENT OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS IN TERMS OF SORT OF
GETTING, I THINK, WHERE WE ARE
TODAY AND WHILE NOT IS MR.
GARCIA, WHILE NOT PERFECT AND
SURELY WE STILL HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL, WE
BELIEVE GENERALLY THAT I THINK
IT'S MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN WORK WITH. AND WE AS WELL
, THINK THE DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO
BE FUNDED APPROPRIATELY.
ADEQUATELY, AND MEET THEIR
REQUIREMENTS UNDER LAW. SO,
AGAIN, WE'RE HAPPY TO BE PART OF
THIS CONVERSATION THE LAST FEW
MONTHS. AND AGAIN, I APPRECIATE
IT. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS, JOHN
NORWOOD, ON BEHALF OF THE ALMOND
ALLIANCE, THE CALIFORNIA POOL
AND SPA ASSOCIATION, FOR THE
ALMOND ALLIANCE, WE APPRECIATE
THE DIALOG AND LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD.
WITH REGARD TO CPSC, WE ACTUALLY
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANKS VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS. TRICIA
GEHRINGER WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA. ALSO
REMOVING OPPOSITION, REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR AND HIS
STAFF AND ALSO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALL THE WORK. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE HERE IN ROOM
113 SEEING NONE. OKAY I'M GOING
TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND SEE IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY. WE HAVE
A MOTION. I WANTED TO JUST GO
AHEAD AND ASK FOR CLARIFICATION
IF, UNDER SECTION ONE, THE
FINDINGS AND DECLARATIONS ARE
THOSE, I KNOW THEY'RE UNDER
FINDINGS AND DECLARATIONS, BUT
ARE THEY GOING TO BE CODIFIED OR
ARE THEY THEY BECOME LAW? OR CAN
YOU GIVE ME A LITTLE BIT OF,
JUST CLARIFICATION ON THE
DECLARATIONS AND FINDINGS? I'M
TOLD THEY'RE NOT CODIFIED. OKAY.
THEY ARE DESCRIBED AS FINDINGS
AND DECLARATIONS. OKAY, GREAT.
ALL RIGHT. WELL WITH THAT, THANK
YOU FOR ANSWERING THE QUESTION,
LOOK, THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES ARE THE HARDEST HIT
BY CLIMATE CHANGE, THAT MEANS
THAT THESE SAME COMMUNITIES ARE
THE ARE ALSO THE MOST IMPACTED
BY PESTICIDE USE. THE CHALLENGES
POSED BY CLIMATE CHANGE AND
PESTICIDE USE TO HUMAN AND
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH ARE NOT THE
SAME. THAT THEY WERE A DECADE
AGO, CLIMATE CHANGE IS
EXACERBATING THE PEST ON THE
FOOD THAT WE GROW, AND WITH
TIME, THESE PESTS CAN BECOME AND
ARE BECOMING MORE RESISTANT.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS ALSO
EXACERBATING PESTS AT HOME. IT'S
INCREASING PESTS AT COMMERCIAL
LOCATIONS LIKE RESTAURANTS,
HOTELS. AND I KNOW THAT SOME OF
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER, THE BEDBUG
OUTBREAK OF 2023. I SURELY DO,
THESE PESTS, THESE PEST ISSUES
REALLY TARGET LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR, AND YES,
90% OF PESTICIDE USE IS IN
AGRICULTURE, BUT THE REST OF THE
PLACES WE DON'T ALWAYS WANT TO,
THINK ABOUT OR WE DON'T ALWAYS
THINK ABOUT THOSE OTHER PLACES
THAT IMPACT US AS WELL, PESTS
ARE A CONCERN FOR OUR HEALTH AND
OUR WELL-BEING. THEY ARE A
CONCERN FOR THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF THE NUTRITIOUS FOOD
THAT WE NEED TO SURVIVE. AND
PESTICIDE USE HELPS ERADICATE OR
SHOULD HELP ERADICATE THESE PEST
ISSUES, BUT WITHOUT ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT OR REGULATION, THE
HARMS OF PESTICIDE USE COULD
OUTWEIGH THE BENEFITS. AND NO
ONE WANTS THAT. TODAY, WE HAVE
TO BE MORE ALERT, CONCERNED AND
PROACTIVE ABOUT COUNTERFEIT
LEGAL PRODUCTS, PRODUCTS THAT
ARE BANNED AND SMUGGLED INTO
CALIFORNIA FOR ANY KIND OF USE.
AS SOME OF US HAD LEARNED FROM A
RECENT LA TIMES ARTICLE ON THE
USE OF BANNED PESTICIDES ON
LEGAL WEED, WITH THAT, I BELIEVE
THERE IS GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO DO
BETTER, AND THIS LEGISLATION IS
A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. I
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK OF ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS, BUT ESPECIALLY
OF THE AUTHOR, FOR THE WORK THAT
HE THAT HE HAS DONE FOR BRINGING
THE STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER AND TO
GET TO THIS POINT AND, JUST ONCE
AGAIN WANT TO COMMEND YOU FOR
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE. AND
WITH THAT, I WILL ASK THE
ASSISTANT TO Þ. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? JUST I CAN THANK YOU
FOR AGENDIZING THIS ITEM A LOT
OF WORK WENT INTO, PUTTING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD. I WANT TO JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS, THEIR PATIENCE,
THEIR COMMITMENT AND THE WORK OF
OUR COMMITTEES. BOTH YOUR
COMMITTEE, JOSH AND THE REST OF
THE TEAM THERE. THANK YOU AGAIN
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ASSISTANT, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FILE? ITEM ONE AB 2113
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATION, SENATORS HURTADO
I, HURTADO I GROVE. ALVARADO.
GIL. ALVARADO, GIL I CORTEZ.
CORTEZ I PADILLA I, PADILLA I.
OKAY. THE VOTE IS FOUR ZERO AND
THE BILL IS ON CALL JUST TO
ALLOW OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE. THANK YOU. SO MUCH. AND WE
WILL TAKE A SHORT RECESS.
OKAY, WE ARE
BACK. WE ARE GOING TO DO A
FINAL, VOTE, ROLL CALL ON THIS
MEASURE. AND, ASSISTANT, IF YOU
COULD PLEASE, TO THE ROLL CALL,
FINAL ROLL CALL. SENATOR GROVE
IS FOR THE VOTE IS FOUR ZERO,
AND THAT BILL IS OUT.
CONGRATULATIONS.